want to visit Barbie land because I
figured out where it is no rollerblading
required though fair warning you might
want to bring your passport
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that accepts that in a world
full of Barbies and cans sometimes it's
best to just be an allen man the
internet was hyped for the Barbie movie
weren't they I swear you couldn't scroll
for more than two seconds on Twitter uh
X threads I don't know you couldn't
scroll for more than two seconds on
insert generic social media feed here
without being bombarded by someone
unleashing their inner kennergy or
rocking their newest hot pink outfits so
of course I had to see if all the hype
was warranted and as I walked out of the
theater I realized yeah I kind of loved
it sure the theme was a bit on the nose
for my taste but man the movie was just
fun across the board and awesome cast of
characters that are just dropped into
the middle of one of the coolest and
most interesting fictional worlds that
I've seen in a long time a world that I
and many others would probably want to
visit if only it were real except it is
real now right off the bat I might have
lost you on that one Barbie land is
clearly meant to be a fictional location
right they even explicitly distinguish
between the real world and the movie and
Barbie land so aren't they clearly
trying to tell us that Barbie land is a
fake World well that's what I thought
initially too but everything else that
we see in the film gives more evidence
to the contrary when Margot Robbie's
Barbie meets with Kate McKinnon's weird
Barbie to discuss the odd things that
have been happening in the world weird
Barbie describes the passageway between
the real world and Barbie land as a
portal considering the fact that portals
don't you know tend to exist here on
Earth that would seem to tell us that
Barbie land is in some separate
Dimension from The Real World however
this is immediately contradicted a few
moments later when weird Barbie admits
that the portal was just a metaphor she
then whips out her trusty instruction
manual courtesy of Mattel to tell Barbie
the step-by-step directions for how to
get from Barbie land to the real world
specifically Los Angeles I've been to
Los Angeles I wouldn't exactly call it
the real world but then again who might
judge to get from Barbie land to La the
instructions tell us that Barbie needs
to take a sports car a speedboat a
rocket ship a tandem bicycle a camper
van a snowmobile and then finally Don a
pair of roller skates to Blade all the
way to Santa Monica a beach now these
aren't so much Google map directions as
they are just a list of modes of
transportation a bee like me telling you
how to get to my house by saying you
have to take a plane a bus in a car
you're missing a few key Tails there we
can also rule out that these comically
pink propulsion devices are meant to be
magical both Ken's and Barbies as well
as real humans are able to travel freely
back and forth between Barbie land and
the real world provided they follow
these instructions either forward or
backward so while the idea of trying to
find the real world Barbie land might
seem dumb at first it is possible
according to the canon in the movie and
that's the kind of fine line that we
love to ride on this channel so instead
of finishing my barbinheimer double
feature I bid my family Ado and rushed
home unfurled the world map and tried to
pinpoint exactly where Mattel is hiding
Barbie land and let me tell you despite
the movie seemingly going out of its way
to dissuade theorists like us from doing
exactly that they gave us just the
perfect amount of breadcrumbs that led
us right to the doorstep of that pink
Paradise oh I figured you out Mattel
you're gonna have to try a lot harder
than that to keep your boy matpat from
going to live out his dream of being a
Barbie girl in a Barbie world so grab
your pink stilettos Birkenstocks and
Google Maps dear theorists as I once and
for all chart a course to Barbie land
let's start by throwing out some
possible locations that Barbie land
can't be in the movie one of the
characters asks if Barbie land is in an
alternate reality basically asking the
movie the exact question that I
desperately needed the CEO of Mattel
played by Will Ferrell says that you can
think of it as a small town in Sweden
now it's clear that in this moment he's
trying to change the subject after all
his main aim in the movie is to make
sure that Barbie land in the real world
stay as isolated as possible that said
could Barbie land actually be in Sweden
no several times throughout the movie we
see characters taking a sports car just
outside of Barbie land only to find
themselves in a desert Sweden is many
things a desert it is not this
information also allows us to rule out
my sneaky early pick for Barbie land
which was Wisconsin as it turns out
Barbie the toys canonical Hometown is
the fictional city of Willows Wisconsin
since this movie did such a good job of
making deep cut references to past
Barbie lore would have been fitting to
see Barbie land's real location pin
homage to her lesser known home but alas
Wisconsin is the antithesis of a desert
so our search must continue now as much
fun as it be to rule out every single
location on Earth One by one there has
to be a more straightforward approach to
solving the mystery eventually I
realized that instead of just trying to
eliminate where Barbie land couldn't be
we had to follow the route laid out by
the movie we needed to use each mode of
transportation and then cross-reference
locations on the map to see if we could
create a travel itinerary that would
actually find Barbie's Malibu dream
house and uh not to bury the lead here
but uh it's not as easy as just being in
Malibu since we obviously don't know our
starting location the only thing we can
really do is go through our
pre-established journey in Reverse
starting in Los Angeles and then working
backwards through the modes of
transportation until we eventually
stumble our way back into Barbie land
the first leg we need to look into is
Crossing into California while wearing
neon and roller skates the way it's
phrased in the movie is a little bit odd
it goes like this quote the snowmobile
will take you most of the way to the
state of Los Angeles where you will Don
neon and rollerblades and enter the
country of California now clearly there
are some mistakes there a recurring joke
throughout the movie is that the Barbies
are overall ignorant to real world
things so weird Barbie getting confused
about the difference between states and
countries is no big prize it's also
worth noting that while weird Barbie is
saying this she's clearly pointing to
the Los Angeles area on the map so you
could argue that she doesn't really mean
Crossing into the border of the State of
California at all regardless I tried to
solve this one in two different ways the
first was taken what she said literally
and looking at the closest places where
Barbie could cross into the state of
California after having just got off of
a snowmobile the three states that
immediately surround California are
Oregon Nevada and Arizona taking an
aerial view of those three potential
entry points one of these things is
clearly not like the others well Arizona
and Nevada are clearly scorching deserts
Oregon it's a much better fit for our
snowmobile stop it has plenty of
snow-capped mountains and a thriving
snowmobile industry it also conveniently
enough had not just one but two
snowmobile rental spots just across the
Oregon California border in the town of
Medford so we drop off our snowmobiles
in Medford lace up our roller skates and
head on down the California coastline
until we get to Sunny Los Angeles is
what I'd be saying if it wasn't such a
long trip see if we're crossing the
border all the way up at the north we
are now forced to skate the entire
length of California and that is a long
trip that is taking 11 plus days to get
down to Los Angeles I mean Barbie's not
one to Skip Leg Day and if we want to
take weird Barbie outer word it's our
most probable bet but is it our best bet
so I took another look if we wanted
somewhere that was a bit closer Lake
Tahoe area tucked right here away in the
Sierra Nevada mountains is a slightly
closer possibility for this penultimate
leg of the journey but not by a whole
lot you see starting from here Ken and
Barbie are spending about six days in
roller skates trying to get down to
Hollywood better but still in the realm
of ridiculous I don't know to me both of
these routes just felt too far-fetched
which made me think that weird Barbie
was just off in her map reading skills I
mean the maps in the movie leave a lot
to be desired in terms of accuracy like
here we see that New York is practically
up in Canada and England is down near
the equator making London a Tropical
Paradise rather than the cool foggy Town
it normally is and again in her
directions weird Barbie already
flip-flopped State and Country so I
decided to tackle this a second way
maybe what she was meaning to say is
that after snowmobiling you cross into
the County of Los Angeles in the state
of California which then gives us a lot
more realistic possibilities
specifically here the San Gabriel and
San Bernardino Mountains literally an
hour's Drive outside of Los Angeles here
we have ourselves beautiful snow-capped
mountains perfect for snowmobiling and
better yet perfect for rollerblading
into the city at a mere 12 to 14 hour
Journey it's certainly long but it is
far more attainable than the multi-day
or even multi-week trips of our other
options so I'm gonna move forward using
that as my Waypoint what's next on the
journey prior to heading to California a
Ken and Barbie take a tandem bike
followed by a camper van well that
sounds like a backpacker's dream we're
back to the same situation we were in
with the rollerblades you can basically
take a bike in a van just about anywhere
you want to leading to infinite
possibilities luckily we get ourselves
some visual detail that actually paint
for us a much clearer path in the movie
we get a montage of Barbie and Ken
riding as they go through each leg of
their Adventure in the tandem bike
section we see them riding through a
field of tulips and windmills now when I
see tulips and windmills the first place
my mind goes to is the Netherlands or
Denmark but if I felt rollerblading down
an entire State seemed ridiculous biking
across the Atlantic yeah I tend to make
some dumb theories but that one is just
a bridge too far then I realized well
sure it looks Dutch or Danish that could
just be an aesthetic Choice there must
be places that are much closer that look
like it came straight out of a postcard
from Europe and sure enough there are
doing a quick Google search you see that
Holland Michigan is riffing off its
namesake tulips and windmills for days
but still that's all the way across the
country there has to be something a bit
more realistic something a bit closer to
the destinations that we've already
mapped out and indeed there is ladies
and gentlemen meet Solvang California a
small town located just outside of Los
Angeles that's decked out to look
exactly like a Danish Town Complete with
the Tulips and windmills and apple
Stever Solvang looks exactly like the
tandem bike ride that we see in the
movie and it's a mere 13 hour bike ride
just outside the city limits hmm looks
like we're starting to see a pattern
here fun side note by the way Solvang is
where our head of production Jason
actually got engaged good to know that
Joe 's marriage is unironically helping
me to solve an insane theory about the
geography of the Barbie Universe years
later hashtag blame Jason more like
hashtag thanks Jason also on your way
there make sure you check out the pea
soup at the nearby restaurants that
seems random and it definitely is but
it's just what the highway restaurants
advertise over in that area and it's
pretty good anyway after a gentle tandem
bike ride through our discount
Copenhagen our plastic Pals can rent a
camper van and make their way to the San
Gabriel mountains where they'll then
snowmobile around Mount Baldy before
rollerblading down to Hollywood so far
so good and all nicely contained within
this nice little pocket of Southern
California which brings us to the
absolute dumbest leg of the trip the
rocket ship in the Montage of Barbie and
Ken's Journey we see that they ride a
literal rocket into space at first this
made me think that Barbie land was an
interplanetary destination but no I'm
not quite so sure live and Barbie be
canonically an alien would be hilarious
and very on brand for where we are in
2023 the step before this is riding a
speedboat and you wouldn't exactly be
able to find any place to run a
speedboat over on Mars so I think we're
still dealing with Earth here in fact in
that same scene we also see a brief
glimpse of the earth and a suspicious
looking pink shape that kind of looks
like the outline of Barbie land if
that's true then that means that the
rocket ship is a bit of a fun detour for
Barbie and Ken allowing them to launch
from and then return back to the same
spot that being said we still need to
find the place that this would happen
preferably in tandem biking distance
from Solvang California so where could
you possibly find a rocket ship oh will
you look at that located just 26 miles
outside of Solvang is none other than
the Vandenberg space Force Base which
features rocket launch pads that are
being used by both NASA and SpaceX what
are the odds that a Spaceport of all
things would be so close to our knockoff
Denmark it's almost like the writers
planned it this way the launch pads also
happen to be just a stone's throw away
from dozens of bike shops that allow for
a tandem getaway to the quote Danish
capital of America no I'm not making any
of this up this is how cleanly all of
this stuff maps onto itself the space
Force Base also butts up against the
Pacific Ocean the perfect landing spot
for a speedboat putting it all together
it's hard to deny it feels like we're on
the right track we've made it almost the
entire way back to Barbie land we are so
close I could practically smell the
plastic so from Vandenberg we need to
find a boat route that grants us access
to a desert that can then be crossed via
the Barbie sports car then and only then
will we finally be able to locate the
mythical city decked out in Pink Ladies
and Gentlemen toys and girls I think I
found the route Barbie land is located
in none other than drum roll please
Monterey Mexico yeah Barbie and the Gang
are living la Vida Rosa down in Mexico
Monterey located in the northeastern
state of Nuevo Leon is a beautiful city
flanked on its western side by what dear
theorist a massive Chihuahuan Desert by
crossing the desert by car you'd reach
the Gulf of California in about eight to
ten hours from there you can board a
speed boat and ride your way all the way
up the coast to Vandenberg space Force
Base then catch a quick ride on one of
Elon musk's Rockets go into low earth
orbit and back before renting a tandem
bike to ride all the way to Solvang
catching a view of the tulips after that
run a camper van and ride up to the San
Gabriel mountains where you'll ditch
your van for some cool snowmobiles ride
around until lacing up some rollerblades
and taking the scenic route through
California to finally reach the
quote-unquote real world of Los Angeles
now why would I choose Monterey
specifically admittedly when you look at
the complete map of the journey there
are definitely some places that are
closer to Southern California that can
still fit the bill of deserts built up
against an ocean but consider this what
else is located in Monterey Mexico but
none other than the world's largest
Mattel Factory with over 200 000 square
meters of space and over 3 500 employees
Monterey is the perfect home for Barbie
in the movie because it quite literally
is the home for Barbie in the real world
literally Barbie land the land that
makes all the Barbies and houses all the
Kens and Allens and Skippers of the
world but as one final point of evidence
to seal the deal in the movie when Ken
starts to go hyper masculine in his
kennergy we do see some Ken's actively
building a border wall outside of Barbie
land now I recognize that right there as
a political landmine but don't blame the
messenger I'm not the one who's doing it
I'm just saying it's in the movie and
the subtext is obvious an army of
kendals building a border wall yeah it's
just further evidence to prove that
Barbie land is at or near the U.S Mexico
border exactly where Monterey and its
Mattel Factory is where then is Barbie
land it's not as crazy of a question as
you might think it's a rollerblade bike
ride snowmobile speedboat away from Los
Angeles or you know a three-hour flight
from LAX even though the movie gives us
all these convoluted directions that
seem so LOL random but they really laid
out for us was a series of breadcrumbs
giving us all the information we needed
to track Barbie back to the source the
literal Source her Factory in Mexico
sadly when you look at pictures of the
place though it's not coated in neon
pink maybe one day we can at least dream
but hey that's just a theory a film
Theory and cut hey if you could do me a
favor and focus all your energy on that
subscribe button that would be awesome
or maybe you're in the mood for another
video about Barbie that's the case check
out our most recent style Theory again
on the Barbie movie that one's on screen
right now
laughs